for millions of americans office jobs
can feel like the only jobs but for
workers like me to be here hey
long time no see yeah
there need to be people like mohammed
celine who for the past 10 years has run
a newsstand inside the cbs broadcast
center in manhattan it was a dream
location for him and his wife shista
this is a monday to friday business
right and like morning to evening not
too many long hours this was a good job
to have good chapter but as the
coronavirus spread in march of 2020 it's
going to be a new reality in this city
the city the nation and our building
closed meaning the salines were closed
as well for more than a year when they
finally could reopen they found
thousands of dollars worth of expired
food that had to be tossed and
repurchased if you don't mind me asking
what portion of your savings have you
had to spend
to stay afloat approximately i spent
already twenty five thousand dollars
mohammed has been driving for uber while
waiting for his business to bounce back
but so far new york's grand reopening
hasn't been so grand how does the foot
traffic and the business today
right now 10 people are here in the
building
wow right used to i do one thousand
dollars sale for
the day per day for before
now is like approximately 200 hours oh
wow
and what's happening here is happening
all over before the pandemic new york's
hudson yards opened four gleaming new
office towers and dozens of retail and
food locations to serve the workers
inside them
workers who are only just now and just
barely trickling back first day back
since february two thousand first order
wow how many people are back in your
office not not everyone and you got to
be flexible everybody's got their own
decisions to make but i mean is it like
10 back 30 back 20 20 20 yeah 20
okay that means a lot less business for
people like the local dry cleaner hi
is the manager here in buildings where
her delivery guy once collected heaps of
business casual office clothes to be
cleaned and pressed he now sometimes
walks away with nothing so this is
pre-covered business booming big cart
right this is now now sometimes it's
empty
lately she's been calling long-time
customers to find out when or if their
business might return i try to make with
the customer like a
family like a friend yeah so like hey
how are you doing huh how are you doing
like you always say that to them and
then are they going to come back to you
yes but someone said oh
i work at home i'm with my mom you know
what can i say oh okay when you coming
back i don't know maybe yes maybe not
the reality is some may never come back
office vacancies across the u.s have
risen above 16 percent
and one survey shows three quarters of
companies here in new york still have no
plans to bring employees back to the
office full time hey guys how are you
that fact is killing the hudson yards
cafe
and the food cart's co-owner alex campos
how were things going before
coronavirus oh excellent excellent yes
excellent
but now business is still down 95
pastries that used to sell out by 10 in
the morning still crowd the window long
after lunch
and when we met him alex was close to
his breaking point i mean i've been
working really hard
[Music]
is having a moment yeah all these months
later
it's still difficult to process
you okay bud yeah
how it all went so wrong so quickly
and why towers that should be filled
with people
are not
you okay yeah
what are you thinking what are you
feeling right now i work too hard and uh
i think
for one day you just lost everything
uh and there are a lot of livelihoods at
stake here businesses like food carts
dry cleaners newsstands you add them all
up and it employs more than 150 000
americans that was as of 2019
28 almost a third of those jobs
disappeared last year alone and that may
only be the start of a major shift
according to one expert we'll talk about
in in our next hour this could be the
beginning of the end of this model i
mean my eyes almost fell out of my head
when muhammad in our building told me he
spent 25 thousand dollars of his own
savings just to restock his store
and it's not like we're all back in
business here and he's making his his
money back he's not tony what i love
about your journalism and the reporting
that you do is you often make us think
about our place in the world and how
we're interconnected with the world
around us in ways that we don't
sometimes consider
mr sullen lives he works in our building
and we hadn't thought about that nope
i'd never thought about that never
thought about dry cleaning and was
really touched by the man
who got emotional with you and when he
said something very poignant when he
said i work so hard and then you lose it
all in one day through no fault of your
own right i don't know and you know
he's at the pinnacle of his career he
and his partner worked for years to get
a corner like that with four new
buildings
he was set up to make money uh and
instead it's just gonna go away that 150
000 number for jobs i mean that that's
the size of the oil and gas extraction
industry in this country that's bigger
than the coal industry it's it's a major
part of our economy
and it's really hurting it takes me back
to what tony fauci said anthony fauci
said when he was here that we can
control this if we do the right thing
and get the vaccine everybody can go
back to work yeah you can go back to
work and culturally though we may decide
we don't want to yeah if mr saleem is
watching i'm coming downstairs today
yeah i'm going to be buying some food
all right i'm sure it is
all right and tomorrow our series the
work shift will look at the exodus from
big cities into small towns and rural
areas during the pandemic as people move
closer to nature see how these
population changes have unintended
consequences like soaring absolutely
soaring housing prices but first it is
811. time to check your local weather